[Music]
do you have plans to me do you want to
have fun with me later
Courtney Holmes I have mildly surprised
but offer accepted midnight basement
sublevel see what's going on I would
like you to stop my heart you give it
one minute and then you bring me back
okay now is the point where you say it's
all the joke
[Music]
what happens to us after we die the only
way to find out is to see for ourselves
we could document that experience did
you see a white light it was more like
pure energy
how is she playing the piano now it's
like her brain's been rewired I'm going
next charging 200 it's a good day to die
[Applause]
everyone I touched today I'm gonna heal
so don't wait three minutes Jamie Eileen
did too what can I say
we're competitive I'm going next five
minutes seven minutes
no one's ever come back from that
[Music]
was it all fun
is there anything disturbing something
is happening to us
I'm going crazy maybe we open the door
[Music]
something is a copy something I did
because she's not stabilizing this
experiment needs to end right now
wake up should have told you this wasn't
about science er discovery
four minutes I didn't know the side
effects would show up and start humming
us down
this was my fault
[Music]
[Music]